hello friends and wonderful people
welcome to part 2 of my tales from the
comment section for Star Wars the last
Jedi also want to give you a fair
spoiler warning there are gonna be some
spoilers in these comments just so you
know I feel like if you were gonna watch
the last Jedi you have watched it by now
in a world where my parents have seen
the last Jedi by now I feel like a
hundred percent of the people who would
watch this video I've seen it do shi Mei
are you ready yeah so let's get to know
Snoke didn't leave ran kylo Ren he lied
well of the five stages of acceptance
you're in denial right now a lot of
people online
they've hit anger there's a petition to
get Rian Johnson's episode eight light
from Canon I would say they're in
bargaining then people will reach
depression and then acceptance and I'm
certainly not exempt from this when I
watched the movie and I was like maybe
there's something I missed I should
watch it again that was me in the
bargaining phase of acceptance also so
Ben they're not he threw the lightsaber
because Ben used it and it reminded him
of Ben now there was a rumor online that
the lightsaber that Ben Sola used to
block Luke Skywalker's strike and that
flashback scene is that blue lightsaber
at first I was like is that the blue
lightsaber I saw screencap of it and it
doesn't look like that blue lightsaber
it happened so fast it's really hard to
tell it would make sense of kylo Ren go
and that lightsaber that belongs to me
but I always thought it was like a
birthright thing which then negates the
whole birthright thing and it being
Darth Vader's lightsaber or Anakin
Skywalker's lightsaber his grandfather
so I just think it was just an attempt
at humor it was just a metaphor for hey
you expect what ha what was the point of
Luke apologizing to Leia about having to
kill kylo when he wasn't even physically
there to harm him I agree with you on
that there's also the line Luke
Skywalker says to kylo Ren something
like strike me down and I will always be
with you like your father but really
that can't happen because he's not there
so why did he even say that again the
balance between going in an unexpected
direction and giving fans pay off Luke
died because making a forced projection
of himself across the galaxy used up all
of his energy huh I got that
I also remember Luke Skywalker saying he
came to that island to die not even
counting the
fact that there are enough cliffs on
this thing to get the job done if you
want to die there are ways to take care
of that there the fact remains he could
have just forced projected himself and
then ended up killing himself for
becoming one with the force it on the
way I didn't do that Jeremy this comment
was actually in my spoiler review the
video where I actually do write the
movie so how about having the balls to
watch your video before you comment just
hang in Huck's kind of annoys me because
he screams all the time oh so now you
see what it's like okay alright that was
well played I do tend to project like
alright good for you you take a victory
lap my man misspelled hawks kylo Ren
quoted Darth Vader II was trying to
convince Rey to rule the galaxy together
just like Anakin said to Patton man
again I think poetry so that they rhyme
guess rebels feel pretty stupid for not
kamikaze hyper driving through Death
Star back in the day maybe but I do give
this one a pass or if it's a flaw it's
not a flaw created by the last Jedi
that's a flaw created by the original
Star Wars movie in the original Star
Wars new hope
han Solo is talking about how he has to
chart the course to Lightspeed looks
like why not just do it Han Solo says
something along the lines that
Lightspeed ain't like Dustin crops boy
if you don't do it right if you don't
chart the course you can run through an
asteroid or fly through a star and it'll
end your trip real quick so we see right
there in the original Star Wars it does
save that Lightspeed ships can hit
matter and hit objects and if an
object's goin that fast yeah it'll blast
right through so the fact that they
didn't actually take a ship and Ram it
into light speed through the original
Death Star in the original movie that's
a plot hole created by the original
movie the last Jedi is just taking that
concept and doing something with it so
tonight they give props the last yet
after that I have faith that JJ Abrams
is not done with snook we'll find out
more about him in episode 9 oh I do
agree that that is a possibility but if
that does happen as JJ Abrams go and
look man I wasn't done with Snoke I'm
bringing him back somehow
thanks Ryan Johnson for killing him he
didn't mention the kid with the broom
and what are your thoughts about it I
imagine that is some solid setup for the
books the casino planet scene was there
to reveal a new side
this universe away from the empire rebel
thing new bad guys if you will why does
nobody noticed that yeah I think people
see it they get it it's just terribly
executed I be for example the prequels
introduced a new angle to everything
with space politics just because you
introduce a new angle doesn't mean it's
well executed and I just do not think
what's it called canto bite I said I
don't think that was well like skin no
man that was not in the army when you're
in a fight you do not discuss orders you
fulfill them well it's true I was not in
the military and if this is any
indication it's probably best because I
probably questioned every stupid order I
get but this comment almost implies
we're holding Star Wars to the letter of
military law so at that point are you
gonna tweet Rian Johnson and be like man
who was not in the military but someone
commits mutiny they're to be executed
for treason at that point are you gonna
start some sort of petition to have Poe
Dameron executed in the movies keep in
mind Rian Johnson was never in the
military either so it's just a
scriptwriter making a story arc the fact
that it doesn't line up with military
procedure is not why it doesn't make
sense the fact that Laura Dern's
character was being uselessly secretive
unnecessarily secretive that's why it's
stupid
I think the awkward kiss was kind of the
point she likes him he doesn't like her
well then my question would be why even
have the kiss it just makes it awkward
why not have the line we fight for the
things we love and have that be enough
you kind of know where she's coming from
there's no weird awkward kiss to make
the moment weird is there blowing a hole
in the rebel base but in the world where
it's all about execution that just
wasn't well executed been in roses art
being pointless is the whole point of
the arc though sometimes the solution
doesn't work it's a subversion of our
expectations just like much of the movie
you to know and I have to address this
if you are going to make the excuse well
it being pointless was the point of it
in the movie you have to give that break
to every other movie that might have
something pointless useless or stupid in
it too because it could be done for
anything just like the people in
Twilight we're supposed to be
emotionless and indifferent because it's
a parallel to how they're detached from
humanity and people don't get them
they're in a world that's not like that
you could always do that or how about
this one
in Batman and Robin mr. freeze was
supposed to have cheesy ass humor
because he's emotionless
he doesn't actually get humour so he's
trying to emulate it so it makes sense
no it doesn't it's stupid [ __ ]
writing hold it to a standard the dumb
canto bite planet was created to sell a
book and the story arc Finan ros ron was
completely useless and wasted john
boyega's talent not a good reviewer if
you withhold your judgement on a film
just to see it again to convince
yourself that you like it more this is
actually a really loaded comment for me
but I didn't hold out on writing the
movie because I wanted to like it more I
just wanted to see it again to be sure
about the reasons it didn't actually
resonate well with man and that was just
initially then when the reviews went
live and a lot of people I know
colleagues were like this is the best
Star Wars movie I was like okay
obviously there was something I missed
so I really need to see this movie again
I need to see what wasn't working here I
watched it and I was like I don't see
what they see but they see what they see
and I see what I say which is a bummer
because that was an admitted moment of I
think very human self-doubt and I
shouldn't have done that should have
been like I know exactly what we're
going for done it with confidence like I
did when I reviewed Suicide Squad this
was the first time I got where Star Trek
fans were coming from when they saw the
Abrams Star Trek movie they were like
this is not Star Trek I feel like that's
what this is this is not Star Wars in
this sense that every Star Wars trilogy
before and every chapter in those
trilogies every chapter was its own
chapter but its springboard and off of
what came before it and it left room for
what was coming after it the prequels
for all their flaws are moving forward
to a conclusion I feel like Rian Johnson
when making this movie was like all
right Abrams what you were setting up
not going there in fact was coming after
this don't care I'm making this isolated
box island of a movie it threw me off at
first I was like I didn't just see that
I think that's unfair in order for a
Star Wars movie to work I feel like
everybody probably should have had a
powwow a confab but like this is where
we're going so let's stay on that path I
walk out into a world where people are
praising a Star Wars movie for going in
bold new directions and in the end the
thing that happened that they're talking
about the bold new directions the fact
that snook was killed what else were
they talking about if not that I mean I
guess the point of unexpected is this
movie isn't some bold new direction with
Star Wars there were just unexpected
things that happened in it I didn't
expect Snoke to die I didn't expect to
raise parents to be nobody I didn't
expect Luke to force projects I wasn't
that what else is unexpected I didn't
expect the resistance to slowly escape
the first order that would follow them
slowly also didn't expect a stupid
gambling planet I just feel like these
unexpected actions that happened in the
movie are passing the movie off as some
brilliant great movie unexpected doesn't
mean good but in the end you could have
Snoke beat kylo around to death with a
box of dildos it'd be unexpected would
make it good right there you can see
there's a difference between unexpected
and good the other thing I see for
people like no that was bold new and it
was unexpected it's the whole canto bite
thing and fin and roses arc and how in
the end it was completely useless they
were like yeah it was useless ain't that
brilliant I just don't know how that's
brilliant
other than the argument of will they
failed and you didn't see that coming
it's new that would be to imply failure
is new in Star Wars
like when imperial troops invaded the
hoff base Luke failing at his trial
Luke facing Vader and failing there I'm
frozen in carbonite and Leia fails to
rescue him this doesn't even count the
prequels for the Jedi completely and
totally failed if for nothing else think
of this The Phantom Menace is a Star
Wars movie but the unexpected direction
was taken with midi-chlorians did anyone
go into the Phantom Menace expecting
microscopic bacteria to explain a
connection between the force and people
no that's an unexpected thing ergo the
Phantom Menace is good knows that's also
another thing I was struggling with was
like there are things in the last Jedi
that irritated me that parallel
irritations I had with the prequels and
if they irritate me in the prequels I
have to irritate me here but I also feel
like people who give it a pass here have
to give it a pass for the prequels just
the last Jedi put me in a very
interesting mindset so I just needed to
watch it a couple times before I
actually committed again it's the
conflict in my head of is this a good
movie and if so is it a good Star Wars
movie you can be one without the other
and that's how I see this movie a fine
sci-fi movie but it's not really a Star
Wars movie to me I will give this new
trilogy props and being unexpected the
fact that they're killing off the entire
old crew when you see interviews of
Kathleen Kennedy and they're talking
about how Kathleen Kennedy is gonna take
the characters George created and
bringing them to a new generation
they're just killing them off and I just
step back and I go I'm not feeling
resolution with these deaths
I feel more resolution in leaving them
in Return of the Jedi where they left
off in Return of the Jedi gave me
resolution for their characters then you
just rehab
them and you're killing them off and
very unfulfilled ways that resolutions
now gone forever with their characters I
don't like that I'd rather just be like
nope return the Jedi ended their but
ultimately I'm pretty proud of my Star
Wars spoiler review I addressed a lot of
things that bothered me in the movie and
in the end I rated it a good time no
alcohol required because I do find it a
fine sci-fi movie but it really isn't
what I know to be a Star Wars movie
alright folks so that is it for my tales
from the comments section for the last
Jedi got a little long-winded at the end
but I figure if I'm gonna put a bow on
this thing I'm gonna put a bow on it
that's just how I feel
Granta I can do one every week because
the comments keep pouring in and more
people who watch it the more people
bring things up the more people react to
that the more comments I get so this
could really keep going every week it's
not going to necessarily go every week
but I just wanted I wanted to give you a
two videos instead of one but I really
want to know what you guys think about
it and since Star Wars the last Jedi is
a couple weeks old at this point if you
can tweet this out pass it around that
would really help me out too I'd
appreciate that help alright so Star
Wars the last Jedi have you seen it
again have you seen it a couple times
has your opinion changed really curious
about that was your opinion solidified
when you saw it the second time whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here oh [ __ ] I totally forgot you
were there the entire time I got a
little long-winded I was like in the
zone I really feel bad I'm sorry I
solved a Rubik's Cube during your speech
do you want the outro you can do the
outro you're like punch go for it it's
all you that's acceptable trivia yeah
there's always if you like what you seen
here and you want to see my good idea to
see
[Music]